slow cooked fiery lamb
cooking's all about being bold and
adventurous and this dish is exciting
because it's slowly cooked and the
longer it cooks the more flavoursome it
becomes
marinating the lamb first chillies we're
going to use a mixture of red and green
take off the tops
and just slice
in
garlic
crushed
don't worry about chopping these ultra
fine just
get it in there
cooking
for up to three hours
everything sort of blends and almost
sort of
purees itself together
smoked paprika goes brilliantly well
with the chilis
two teaspoons in a touch of dried
oregano
some little cumin seeds the blend and
the fragrance that they give out
is extraordinary they release a little
oil as well and helps to tenderize the
lamb a touch of salt
pepper
cinnamon
that sort of sweetens up the lamb
olive oil just a tablespoon and the
olive oil helps to sort of stick all
those wonderful spices to the lamb jump
in
just start really rubbing at this stage
you can leave the lamb to marinade for
anything from half an hour to overnight
allowing the spices to really penetrate
the meat giving amazing results when you
tuck in delicious
vegetables carrots and onions and that's
it sliced
secret slicing vegetables from braising
is not getting too thin you slice the
onions too thin they burn you've got
that horrible char taste on that slow
braised braising it's just a chef's term
that means cooking in liquid on a low
heat making the meat incredibly moist
and beautifully tender so the secret of
braising is having a really nice thick
durable pan
get that nice and hot
just a touch of olive oil
lamb in hold the bone because you're in
control then into the pan
i want that white fat to start rendering
so it'll add more fat therefore making
it a lot more flavoursome as it
braises chili's
cinnamon
in
mix that up
and don't be scared you're not burning
this you're sort of searing the lamb
shanks and this is the important part
right at the very beginning we're
getting the colour on the lamb which
washes off as it braises in the oven so
be generous with that color
vegetables in
wow and then a couple of baileys
so now you lift the lamb up
and get the lamb
sat
on top of the vegetables
now just glaze the pan with red wine
the glazing means that you're you're
cleaning the bottom of the pan and
you're getting that amazing flavor
washed off and lifted up into that sauce
can really transform that dish always
delays
then bring to the boil and cook for
about 10 minutes to reduce
the wines reduce down by half now for
the stock
bring that stock back up to the ball and
then into the oven now don't cover it
when you cover it all the condensation
comes off the lid your lamb becomes gray
all this effort and that exciting spice
gets washed away no lid and in the oven
for three hours
a slow cook on a low heat of 160 degrees
gives the spices time to work and
transform the meat so it's
mouthwateringly tender
now
look at those
out on to a plate you can just see that
meat sliding down
juicy and incredibly tender grab it by
the
the shank roll around that rich
delicious sauce
look at
and get that sauce nice
beautiful
just get some mint
don't chop it
just pick that fresh mint and let it
snow
and there you go a very spicy delicious
melting of the mouth lamb shank amazing
red mullet with sweet chilli sauce
cooking is about being adventurous and
having the confidence to go off piste
and being a little bit more daring so
when you start combining peanuts chili
flakes and this amazing fish red mullet
trust me you're in for an amazing treat
we're gonna make a really nice light
sweet chilli sauce
first off your chili
off with the top
in half
and those seeds inside
are very powerful
incredibly
hot
but full of flavor garlic
two cloves of garlic
slice the garlic nice and thin
so it helps to puree
the chilies in the pest and water garlic
in
such a salt a little touch of sugar
in
and then start grinding
push down first
[Music]
the salt and the sugar
really helps to puree the chili and the
garlic
fish sauce always a base
to a chili sauce two tablespoons in
and a touch of rice wine vinegar
fish sauce gives it the saltiness the
vinegar
gives it a nice acidic wake up three
tablespoons
of olive oil
nice
mix that up
beautiful look at the colors incredible
now spring onions i want the texture
and the crunch spring onions in
the coriander slice it once
in
fresh lime
and that goes brilliantly with the red
mullet just really wakes up the chili
the garlic and reminds the sauce that
we're serving with fish now taste
wow that's delicious look at that
beautiful
the longer that chili sauce sits there
the better it gets now for the peanuts
and chili that's gonna coat the top of
the red mullet
peanuts in
salt
in that helps to really grind the
peanuts down some beautiful dried chili
flakes creates a nice sort of warm
heat i'm using fresh chili for the sauce
but dried chili flakes for the coating
which will really crunch up when cooking
just a little bit of coriander
mix the coriander in
to the peanuts
and look i like them quite textured i
don't want them too small as a powder
otherwise they'll burn but crushed
lightly
to coat the fish with the chili and
peanut seasoning in a separate bowl beat
two eggs along with a splash of fish
sauce
take your fillet
lay
in your red mullet
dip it in shake up your peanuts
and then in and make sure you push that
down
cover that red mullet
up beautiful
now make sure that pan is really nice
and piping hot if you put the fish in
and the pan's cold
all those wonderful peanuts and chilli
just gonna slide off the fish so we need
to sear it in and get it nice and crisp
in and lay away from you
beautiful
[Music]
if the pan starts getting a little bit
too hot
get your olive oil
and just place another teaspoon of olive
oil around the outside so it starts to
heat up as it hits the center and it
really helps to stay so much more in
control
and turn
nice and gently
we want that nice sort of toasted
sauteed
crispness
which adds a really lovely flavor
tilt the pan and just baste
the top of the red mullet with that
really nice piping hot olive oil
you've got that really nice roasted
crunch and it goes brilliantly with that
soft sweetness of that fish inside
get off and just leave them sitting in
there
and finish with lime and just go over
each one
now we'll take them out
and the sauce
will touch on the bottom
and the tail of each fish
now to round that off
serving some fragrant rice
sauteed broccoli
amazing and there you have a delicious
peanut and crusted red mullet with a
wonderful sweet chilli sauce cooking
with chilis isn't all about blow your
head off heat this dish uses the
exciting taste of a chili but has a
deliciously elegant and subtle
flavor spicy beef salad
chillies if you use them confidently
they can really add a new dimension to
the style of cooking but the real trick
is finding that balance of flavors that
really suits you because that's the most
important part
so this is the most amazing sirloin you
can see it's got that wonderful marble
for me the secret behind this
is cooking it quickly season the steaks
generously
salt and pepper
push that seasoning in to the sirloin
take the soda out the fridge literally
20 minutes before you want to cook them
so it gets up to room temperature they
cook more evenly but more importantly
you can actually season
right inside
the steak this little bit of fat down
here season that as well because that is
what we want to roast and get that
really nice and rendered olive oil in a
tablespoon
roll that round
as it starts to smoke in with the steaks
into the pan
and lay away
again
into the pan
and lay away if you don't hear that
noise the minute those steaks hit the
pan don't put them in so the secret now
is getting that color on the steak
turning it once and once only and
cooking it for two and a half minutes
each side what i want to do is to get
that bit of fat rendered so it adds a
lot more flavor just hold
the steak down like that
and that starts to melt the fat which
makes it so much more tender there
should be no white fat left anywhere
turn them over
really important to have that steak up
to room temperature before you start
cooking it so the inside is nice and
warm so we spend less time in the pan
and more time cooling down
really important
now two fingers touch
it goes in says rare
i'm happy for them to be rare because by
the time i let them rest
they're gonna go back to medium rare
it'll continue cooking
out onto a plate and let them rest
one
two
let's get my juices over
don't waste that really important
next the spicy dressing take the seeds
out of the chili to reduce the heat by
rubbing it in your hands and tapping
until the seeds fall out
cut it in half
and just chop it
in
garlic and chilli works brilliantly a
quick way of peeling it get your knife
and just
slam it down
pops out very very quickly in a little
touch of salt
rub
start going around in circles first
you'll see it pureeing
nice clear that off
now we've got the heat in there from the
chilli and that richness from the garlic
two teaspoons of palm sugar this is
where it starts to have that nice sweet
sour effect
fish sauce
fresh lime this is a simple fresh chili
dressing and it was something i fell in
love with in vietnam and cambodia
because it was just so easy
give that a little mix and dissolve
the sugar
quick taste
wow right vegetables
a great fuss-free way to get super thin
ribbons of carrot is to use a veg peeler
when they're that thin they take the
vinaigrette so much better and radishes
just slice them down at an angle
lovely to give another dimension to the
salad i'm gonna use a banana shallot
they are incredibly mellow
very sweet
across
just chop up the shallot
and mix that through
want some sweetness in there now little
vine tomatoes slice them
in half tomatoes in
shallot radish carrots and tomatoes
next peel and slice cucumber
chopped spring onions and shred baby gem
lettuce and then finally get some fresh
mint
there's young men so you don't need to
take all those stalks off all you do is
hold the bunch upside down
and then take it for a little trim
and just chop that once
through
look at that nice
minted
salad a couple of tablespoons of
dressing don't flood the cellar with the
dressing we can always add but we can't
take it away now really mix that
dressing in there make sure all that
chili and garlic and palm sugar wraps
around that salad beautiful
onto the plate the steak's rested it's
now nice and medium rare that little bit
of fat we don't want to find that in the
salad just slice that off that serves
its purpose
it's kept that steak nice and moist
just slice going with the grain it's
almost like
slicing through butter and look inside
beautiful pink
you slice the beef too thinly then it
goes stone cold and more importantly all
the goodness runs out of it
nice thick slices
get the beef and start placing it around
the salad
take a little teaspoon
of your dressing the rest of your salad
sip that on top
we'll finish it off with some toasted
peanuts peanuts in
now those nuts
are really toasted nuts on
get another pan
and just
crush
once they've cooled down
just run them through with a knife
they can hear how crunchy they are
another
texture another taste the salad
and then from there sprinkle
and then finally
take that
just finish it with a little
tablespoon of that sauce
and there is one tasty very well
textured spicy beef salad
[Music]